de la couleur de la symétrie
des cercles concentriques que voyez vous
il faut s'approcher pour comprendre avec
quoi sont faites ces compositions des
plumes
c'est une matière que j'ai toujours vu
dans mon enfance
parce que j'ai une famille de chasseurs
j'adore tout ce qui est matière délicate
légère douce donc ça me parlait comme
matière en fait d'abord lucile vilaine
près par la plume elle la taille pour
enlever le duvet et ne garder que la
partie haute c'est durant ses études
elle a obtenu un diplôme des métiers
d'art en broderie qu'elle découvre le
travail de la plume asri
rares sont les personnes qui ont des
plumes dans leur quotidien comme ça
comme un objet de décoration c'est
plutôt une matière qui est par sa
noblesse en fait utilisé dans le domaine
de la haute couture donc finalement
c'est assez
réservé à certaines personnes et pas à
tout le monde donc moi déjà je voulais
un peu démocratisé cette matière sur ce
papier épais elle a réalisé un gabarit
avec des repères très discret elle s'est
ainsi opposé chaque plume
rien n'est fait au hasard mais si c'est
de la perdre et rouge et le but de cette
collection la collection ligne de mire
où tous les motifs sont circulaires
c'est que sur chaque modèle j'utilise
une seule espèce d'oiseau révélé en fait
la diversité qui peut y avoir sur une
seule espèce que ce soit par rapport aux
couleurs aux motifs ou même aux formes
de plumes en fait qu'on peut retrouver
sur un mois c'est ainsi que faisant
pintades et autres canards trouvent une
seconde vie
le travail est minutieux tout en finesse
c'est quasiment impossible de rattraper
une plume comme ça avec les doigts sans
l'abîmer donc il ya vraiment la pince
depuis maastricht est indispensable qui
va me permettre de pouvoir coller la
plume exactement là on veut sur le
papier et pour donner du volume aux
compositions la créatrice colle à la
route rousse est là en fait la
différence c'est qu'on vient coller non
pas dans le creux de la plume
mais sur le dessus elle va venir se
soulever et on va pouvoir avoir ce
volume qui va être réalisé ce petit jeu
d'ombrés qu'on va venir voir sous les
plumes qui paraissent être des pétales
qui soulève en jouant avec les formes
les couleurs et les nuances cette jeune
artiste rend un bel hommage à la nature